all right Shane hello Shane oh where are
you from originally where'd you grow up
uh I'm from uh South Hill in Limerick
Ireland
um I grew up there I was born in 1987
and I moved to New York in 2012.
um South Hill was the
is a ghetto inside what was at the time
the murder capital of Europe
um I got a preface this every time I
talk about South Hill though it's like
they're good like South Hill they're
amazing people there you know I grew up
around some great people and now it's
it's a much more like it's not as crime
ridden and it's it's a great place and
people don't really like constantly
hearing the term stab City and all that
kind of stuff but uh when I grew up
there it was an absolute [__] just
like an absolute uh hellscape pretty
much I was in like one of the roughest
areas between two feuding drug gangs so
uh we would you know I would wake up
every morning and on top of that then
there was like a joyriding issue in the
neighborhood so people would steal cars
burn them out and leave them in the
field outside our house and um
uh you know like you you'd wake up in
the morning you Google you go out there
be like a freshly burned car and then
you'd try and not get mugged on the way
to school and then that night you might
see guys fighting or something crazy
happening like that
and uh I was there for I was there up
until I was like 13.
um I think it was about 10 years old and
I was walking home from school once and
I saw a guy put his hoodie up block his
face and take out a box cutter and
attack one of my neighbors and they were
scurrying for a while trying to he was
trying to get the guy off him
and I was just sitting there like at 10
I didn't know what to do I was just
watching these guys and then uh
watching the call I just went in for
dinner I just went in went in home we
didn't talk about it you know and that
was kind of like a common thing
um these guys were it was like an eye
for an eye situation in the in the in
the city at the time I think it was like
mainly drugs but um it it spiraled into
like uh I don't know like Revenge a lot
of the time
um and then like shortly after that you
know I was home one night on my own my
house got broken into I was like I was
like 10 or 11 I think and I heard
someone running around upstairs and I
thought my brother had like snuck in the
back door and uh I remember going
through the door I was like holding my
dog and I remember going to the door and
be like Jay like James I was like
calling my brother and uh nothing and
then I I sat back down inside these two
guys came running I could hear them
running down the stairs and the door
opened into the living room and it was
just darkness and I saw some guy there
and I was like who's that and then they
ran out of the house and uh so I'm just
like there on my own pretty much
um
after that you know the house was set on
fire a bunch of times our family car was
set on fire
um and around this time my parents
divorced and uh my mom had a lot of
mental health issues
um at the time I I mean I don't want to
like air all her [__] but you know she
had she was struggling with alcohol
alcoholism
and stuff like that so it was quite we
were stuck there for quite a while the
last like few years we were there it it
kind of got a little bit more peaceful
but uh my dad had built like a makeshift
Glass House onto the front of the house
and uh kids would just throw stones all
day so my mom just had like this crazy
anxiety uh all the time and like bad
depression alcoholism and we'd just be
sitting down eating dinner and
bits of Windows would be breaking this
was like going on for like two years or
something like that
um but we eventually got out of there
and moved to a quieter place but um that
was kind of the foundation for me
growing up
um and then there was some in the
neighborhood there was some uh
I don't want to get into it too much but
there was some sexual abuse stuff that
happened to me and uh so I had this like
beautiful cocktail of just absolute [__]
for the first 10 or 12 years growing up
um
and yeah I'm sure that impacted your
adult life yeah yeah
um I I was always like a very anxious
person I mean you know some of its
genetics some of it's um surroundings
but like growing up um
always just super anxious like socially
very awkward and um but I was kind of
doing okay once we moved out of there
for a while
um
just before we moved out of there my dad
was a politician in um in Limerick
Ireland and uh you know like a small
small City and we didn't have any money
or anything like that but he became
mayor for you know it's like a year term
there and I remember the way we found
out that my parents were splitting up
was the local newspaper had seen him
with someone else and they put it on
like the front page so me and my mom
walked down to the shop one morning and
she found out she was there like all the
neighbors who knew her and stuff she
just looked at the newspaper and like
they were looking at her and I remember
that's how she found out and uh we just
walked back home with the newspaper and
uh
they they started the slow process of
them of divorcing but yeah after that it
was It was kind of okay but when I got
to art school that's when anxiety and
drugs uh experimenting with drugs and
all that kind of stuff kind of came to
the fore and and then I was always like
super angry at my mom because I couldn't
understand why she just like wasn't
happy like why we could be finally doing
something good and she would just
nosedive she would just cut her mood
would completely change and like growing
up I I just like I was I was aside from
all the stuff that happened I was like a
relatively optimistic person like kind
of uh
you know I could always like find the
good in a shitty situation and I taught
I thought she was like faking it for so
long I thought she was um kind of lying
to us or just [__] with us or
something
and I like for most like of my early
life growing up I thought depression
wasn't real I taught anxiety wasn't real
I thought mental health was just like
something you could snap out of but then
it happened to me in art school I just
kind of um I had like a relationship
that was really intense and when it
ended I uh I just like nosedived at
something switched in my brain it like
felt like my brain broke and everything
just caught up to me
and uh I I had I guess something close
to like a mental breakdown and I had to
get a lot of help
um
but uh and then since since art school
to now I'm like 34 now so that was when
I was about 20 or something you know
it's been like a long uh recovery period
trying to like figure [__] out and get
healthy mentally I guess but in those
years I've completely like reassessed
how I see my mom like I see her more as
like a victim now she was there was
there was like nothing she could do
about her state of mind and the more I
learned about her growing up like
I I don't know the full details but like
there was something there with the
Catholic church and Priests like Ireland
is terrible for that kind of [__] like
there's a lot of abusive
uh clergy men and stuff over there and I
know something [__] up happened to her
in her youth
um and uh and then she I mean she had
like ECT and stuff for like like it was
like the
the services or whatever the mental
health services in the country in the
like 60s 70s and 80s was not good like
electric convulsive therapy was like a
thing you do like I would visit her in
psychiatric Wards and stuff when I was a
kid and uh I just never got it but but
then I got a taste of it for myself and
then
my relationship with her was always very
contentious but in recent years it's
been it's been a lot healthier and um I
just feel I just feel bad for her now
you know and uh kind of amazed by her
that she survived at all she also just
likes she decided to just she was like
an alcoholic and this she would like
smoke 60 cigarettes a day and she just
stopped both those things one day like
no recovery rooms or anything like that
she just completely stopped and she was
do she was drinking like while she was
on all these antipsychotic medication
and stuff so she could have really
really been much worse off but um
it's kind of amazing that she's she's
still here and she's like the happiest
she's like 70 years approaching like mid
70s now and she's like the happiest I've
ever known her which is which is really
sweet it's wonderful yeah
and you came to the states yeah I came
to the states in 2012 um so I was in art
school
um and I we were lucky enough to have a
visit to New York and of course like the
whole like if you're an artist or a
musician the whole of Ireland is like uh
one small town like everyone knows
everyone you know and it's very insular
and very tiny and that we came to the
states for a visit with the with the
school and um I I was just like when I
saw New York I was like I'm just gonna
try and [__] move there
um and after school I took a graduate
visa to move there which gets you a year
in the country I like knew no one I had
like I think I managed to get like two
thousand dollars in my bank account and
just landed in New York I had also just
started uh antidepressants and and
anxiety medication at that time so it
was like oh you're anxious like make it
way worse by moving to New York
um but uh so I got here eventually got
set up slowly
um I wanted to move here because um you
know I just grew up on all that stuff
like all the the New York music scene
the the noise stuff the um the the art
scene the the
um Lower East Side art scene and all
that so all that stuff was like super
inspiring to me so
um I moved here and but the first five
years were just a write-off like it was
just um it was just like mental health
ups and downs accommodation like I
remember like my first morning in my
first apartment I woke up with a
cockroach on my face it was I was like
sleeping in a kitchen that was the first
place I rented
um just the usual like Rites of Passage
I guess for New York
um but uh you know I think things are
much better now
um but when I got here the thing that
really flared for me and it had become
kind of a crutch I guess back in Ireland
was um it was slowly like porn addiction
that morphed into sex addiction and um
that kind of took over my life for a
while like that's how I dealt with all
the all the crap that was going on and
all the stress
um again that was the thing I like
didn't think existed you know I was just
like that's such a stupid thing like how
could you be addicted to sex like
everyone is um but there's nothing wrong
with you know like being you know doing
whatever you're doing but when it gets
to the point where you're like not
enjoying it anymore it's just like an
itch you have to scratch you're like
putting yourself in danger you're going
to like really dodgy places hang out
really dodgy people you're not even
attracted to you know uh it starts to
get um a bit rough and uh yeah that kind
of went on pretty hard for a few years
um but I met some good people in New
York who had some of the same issues and
um uh sorting that the addict side of my
personality out has been um very helpful
in getting some of the mental health
stuff on track
um
so yeah New York is a is a insane place
like I love it and I hated an equal
measure
um but there's no there's no place to
like it and I'm kind of glad I stuck it
out for the last 10 years so yeah what's
your favorite thing about New York just
the atmosphere man like you can just
walk just a few streets for a while and
you'll see something weird I mean it's
kind of like here I guess you know um
it's it just has an atmosphere and an
energy that you can't get anywhere else
and like if you're like me if you're a
musician if you wanted to just start a
band tomorrow you just put an ad on
Craigslist and you'll have five people
to jam with or something like that New
York is great yeah it's um it's a good
spot there's no place like it like you
said yeah yeah
and uh
how old are you now I'm 35 Now 35.
relationships yeah I'm married now
um yeah for for me the The Addictive
stuff I guess it was um quote unquote
like sex and love addiction is what they
call it in the rooms um again I thought
I was like that's the stupidest thing
I've ever heard
um when I first heard it but for me you
know I was just like uh going from
relationship to relationship and it was
always so tumultuous and like so intense
and um
I had to like I had to
um stop doing that for a long time and
reassess a lot of that stuff and watch
what I was just watched the brain uh
doing what it does when I see someone
new and like attach myself to them like
super hard
um but in the last uh three or four
years I got married and there was
something about like committing to
someone that really helped
nullify all that constant like crippling
like paralysis by options I guess and
that constant like um
uh hunger for like novelty or whatever
it is like
um it sounds kind of cheesy but like my
friend said it before he's like the best
drug in the world is like sleeping with
strangers you know it's like I've heard
a lot of people say that like aren't we
all sex or love addicts right yeah what
is the difference between being in a
committed relationship with your wife
and living their life that you were
you're calling sex addiction
um I think that when when I when I was
called like in in that like sex addicted
mindset
um like my whole life revolved around it
like I would like you know like you're
on like as many profiles as possible to
like you're like fishing for people all
day you're like what are you looking for
you're looking for any you're looking
for someone who's wild I guess you're
looking for someone who has as little
shame as you do is it the adrenaline
first of all it's the adrenaline when
you when you meet someone new you don't
know where you're going you're in the
new house you it's like uh seeing a
person for like two minutes before
you're naked with them you know there's
something like very like he's just a
huge adrenaline rush but then I think
probably like the real part of it is
like the afterwards where you're like
kind of like relaxed and close to
someone the intimacy I guess it's like a
shortcut to intimacy it's like the
adrenaline and the intimacy and um it's
wanting to get that without putting in
any of the real effort or maybe not
after but like it's like a shortcut to
that mainlining that I guess and doing
it over and over again you know I mean I
would feel like you know like I always I
always I grew up like I just hate the
way I look and I always like very
socially awkward and stuff so like the
fact that you know in my 20s I could
like like I slept with like 10 people
this week like that made me feel like I
was somebody or you hate the way you
look yeah yeah still yeah it's getting
better as I get old I just giving less
of a [__] I guess I don't think I'm
liking it more I think when people are
young yeah in their 20s perhaps they
struggle with that yeah yeah as they age
they you kind of start liking yourself
more or accepting yourself more I think
so yeah yeah I mean you're you're just
you hit with this onslaught of because
you're a handsome young man and I would
I would say like why do you not like the
way you look it's a very sweet of you to
say but yeah I don't know uh
I don't know maybe it's watching too
much American TV growing up I'm not sure
whatever you're so beautiful social
media yeah American TV are terrible for
that but like I went bald when I was
like um I guess we should give an
example but I was involved when I was
like I started noticing it around 16 or
70. your beard makes up for it though
right cheers yeah yeah that helps and
yeah just
stuff like that like I like uh when I
went to art school I got into that that
really intense first relationship like
she was so gorgeous like I couldn't
believe someone that attractive would be
interested in me you know
um it was just like very like I was like
what the [__] is this like I didn't know
it was I was allowed to experience this
kind of thing and then I kind of was
chasing that ever since I think like
self-worth was completely tied to being
able to be side by side with a with like
a attractive woman or something like
that
um and I was just in that for years but
like when you know you do that for so
long eventually you hear a voice in the
back of your head being like dude you're
like what what is this like you're
you're constantly chasing this thing
you're like losing jobs because of it
you're like [__] up relationships
with people you know and stuff and uh
that you can you can choose to like
listen to that voice and see what it's
saying to you or you can just um
keep going down the tunnel I guess
um
like for me it would like with with porn
like and sex like I would I would do it
until I was bleeding I would not care
about what like uh STDs I got you know I
would really worry about it I would care
about the other person I definitely
didn't want to pass anything on to them
but like once I got the all clear again
I would just start the cycle again over
and over again and uh it just it started
getting physically dangerous like I I
was I was in some really rough parts of
town with people who were just out of
their minds on drugs and uh
and eventually you just got to a point
where I was like ah this is not going to
end well so what do you think it stems
from
um I I don't know I could like theorize
that it's something to have to do it
like a having an unstable mother or
something like that like
um my dad I like I love my dad so much
very intelligent guy I'm so lucky to
have had him in my life and but he was
emotionally like uh colder I don't mean
that in a bad way he just he's just
straight and Stern Irish father I guess
and my mom was like the opposite she was
like just like very physical and like
overly doting on me and stuff like that
so it was just like borderline back and
forth but um
something in something in that I guess
like knocked off my um
picker as they say
um you're happy now yeah I'm much
happier now
um
yeah like I I mean part of the main
reason I wanted to like come on here and
talk is that like
uh like I feel like I you know I there's
no like tutting this up against like
what other people are feeling or
whatever but I I feel like in general
like you know I've been in like the
worst of the worst mental health
situation in the sense that like uh you
know I'm the person who would never in
my life want to like kill myself or
commit suicide or anything like that but
it got so bad that like that felt like
like I just wanted the pain to stop I've
been in psychiatric hospitals I was
convinced that like uh you know
depression can't be fixed like there's
no way out of this [__] you just stuck
with it for the rest of your life but um
like I hate it just sounds cheesy and I
hate saying this kind of [__] but with
some work you can really improve your
situation you know you can't like it's
horrible nasty boring [__] work but
um I I look at my life uh around art
school and moving to New York in those
years and maybe some of my earlier years
and like how Bleak and just [__]
awful it was and I look at it now and
I'm just like it can be [__] done
like and I just wanted wanted to say
that like
um if I can do it someone else can do it
like you know I you know I've spent just
I
I just
it's hard to talk about like without
making it sound like a [__] sob story
but like you know like I've spent so
much time just like away from people
convinced that like my life would just
be in a room you know and that I
couldn't interact with people ever again
um you know I I assume that my life was
just going to be heavy medication
forever and I would just be totally
[__] and like I'd be lucky if I could
create any art or talk to any people but
um but just with the help of friends and
with with like the willingness to try
and make things slowly better day by day
to like call yourself out in your
[__]
um to to even though things are [__]
up to like look for some optimism in
life
um and just working at that constantly
like having the desire to actually uh
make things improve and like you know
try and envision a life that might
actually not [__] suck all the time
you can slowly get there over time and I
know it's much harder um it's it's
easier for me to say I guess because I
maybe I'm lucky enough to have like the
gumption to like force it to happen or
whatever I know it's different for
people who are on the street and they're
just stuck in this a cycle of like
addiction and um and just no resources
whatsoever but um but I do believe if
you get some like good help and uh you
you you just keep working at it even
when you like get [__] up again and
just constantly relapse or whatever if
you just try and um stay on it
constantly keep trying to push back
against it you know like progress can be
made maybe you'll not be [__] 100
perfect but there's a huge difference
between like being completely [__] and
like having just a non-life to like like
I'm married now I have two [__] cats
you know I [__] I love my routine I
love [__] just doing the same [__]
thing every day you know and I'm so
grateful that I have a [__] apartment
with a roof over my head you know like I
don't miss being homeless in New York
you know what do you do for work now I
work in a museum in the in the Long
Island City
um I just give I just do ticket taking
and I tell people about some stuff it's
like is there something in your life
that you're passionate about your art
yeah music um I'm like music has been
the thing that's always been a constant
for me it's it's like I'm a visual
artist too but music is the thing I'm
super passionate about when I was like
14 I think at this band called fugazi
came to our shitty little hometown like
in Ireland we were like you know back
then we were like there's Americans in
our hometown so we have to go to the
show I had no idea who they were like
I'd never been to a live rock show in my
life and I remember like standing
outside the venue and I could hear them
sound checking the kick drum in the
venue and it was like reverberating in
my chest outside and I was like I was
like scared I was like what's gonna
happen and we all went in there and for
people who don't know fugazi are like a
DIY kind of straight edge ish punk band
who just like are very they talk very
frankly to the audience about like life
and stuff like that but the next day we
all just like form bands like every
friend I knew we all formed bands the
next day and that was like a complete
Lifeline for me
um I was talking to you a little bit um
in the coming months in the recent
months because I'm on tour at the moment
like I moved to New York in 2012 I
stayed pretty much in New York for the
last 10 years I've seen none of this
country and we're now touring uh like a
DIY tour we builted ourselves just
playing small venues and we're going
along the South all we just made it to
the east coast we're on the west coast
here we just made it here and we're
gonna go up to Seattle and along the top
and back to New York it's a big loop
it's like 10 000 miles and um uh it's
been a crazy experience um like it's
it's been life-changing um like I
wouldn't have been able to do this like
three years ago let alone like five or
eight years ago
um but yeah um
the music and art has just been super
important for me it's like uh being
happy and healthy mentally is
is the key to a lot of it is man it is
like a moment in life right I could I
could I I had it you know I'm always
I've always been engaged in in creating
art and stuff like that um but I I do so
much more now being in a better mental
health space than than I could when I
was the quote unquote tortured artist
like that was just hell pretty much all
like you make work in spite of that
stuff
um but uh but now it's like I feel like
I'm making up for lost time like a few
nights ago we played Slab City this off
the grid community in the desert like it
was just like like I've never been in
the desert before like I'm from Ireland
so like I've never been I was just like
standing there looking at the [__]
desert looking at these people like and
I was just like oh man this is this has
been worth it this is made up like made
up for a lot
um I just want to quickly say too like
um you know growing up like we all like
we're like like America's so exotic it's
like the land of like uh you know like
opportunity or whatever and um you know
nowadays like the the opinion I guess is
a little more negative on America like
um be it true politics whatever like
that and everyone's like [__] American
all this [__] but like the thing that
kills me I don't get it is like
okay like say you hate half the people
in America fair enough that's like what
a lot of us seem to do that right yeah
exactly right and that's like what 175
000 million or I don't know they're
still so you so are all the other people
sucky too does that make America
terrible that's still like millions of
people who are amazing yeah right right
and then on top of that it's like the
[__] geography in this country it's
so gorgeous it's so beautiful the
atmosphere is in the city like I [__]
like it's a it's a it's horrible that
it's like a controversial and like I'm
on the left but like it's a hard it's a
controversial thing to say like I
[__] love America it's [__]
gorgeous I'm not like make America a
great I'm not like whatever whatever you
want to apply to me from just saying
that sentence but like there's amazing
people here like the the history the the
pop cultural history is just insane the
art and the music that has come from
this country is not so for me like
growing up like I'm raised on like
American movies and all that stuff and
um I just it's just [__] depressing
how added to each other's throats
everyone is here it's like you just talk
to people one-on-one and people are just
generally fine you know some are boring
some are great some are horrible but
like in general like that's the thing we
just make these huge generalizations
about massive swaths of people and
that's progress right now you know you
know there's everything here yeah yeah
it's sad that we're at each other's
throats so often yeah yeah and like yeah
so there's everything here and there's
the potential for so much greatness here
like so much Beauty and camaraderie and
stuff like that and it's just being
floundered an opportunity yeah an
opportunity you couldn't what's the name
of your band uh Cinemark or it's like
Cinema and marker like someone who dies
for their religion put together Cinemark
or how do you spell it
c-i-n-e-m-a-r-t-y-r
my [__] Irish accent comes out when I
say it marcher martyr yeah I gotta say
like an American Cinemark Cinemas Carter
yeah I've been saying it to people on
this tour the whole time and they're
like marcher like a marching band but
yeah yeah
uh what do you play in your band uh I
play guitar
um I've been playing guitar since I was
about uh
12 or 13 I guess and um
my motivation with guitar is to like
make a nut sound like a guitar so it's
run through some weird effects and then
we play what is called I guess it's
termed math Rock the the count is off so
it's like a weird count and um
just a
it like you know my life is pretty
structured outside of all this so when I
go on stage That's like [__] Freedom
time and like we've been joking it's
called Uh we're calling it stab rock you
know we have a song called stab City I'm
from quote unquote stab City so that's a
kind of a through line with that because
it's very you know it's very stupid and
Irish is the rest of your band Irish no
it's uh uh amber the singer is from
Nebraska and Davis front the drummer is
from New Jersey and then Aaron is from
Brooklyn uh so we're a bit of a
hodgepodge but yeah excellent fun
traveling the country it's been
beautiful man uh well I'm not gonna lie
uh like I love my routine and what I got
at home so the first three days like
we're we're like a very energetic life
and like we just
trolled out there for the 40 minutes we
have and so you know we're used to doing
that like one or two nights a month in
New York but this was like the first uh
leg of this was like six nights in a row
so like four nights in I was like I'm
good to go home like I get touring now
I'm good so I'm good to leave it but it
was just like a fleeting thought and uh
I'm so glad I stuck around because it's
it's been [__] amazing just to see
weird pockets of this country and like
just random strangers putting us up in
their living rooms and stuff like that
um it's just been so nice and I think
I'll have a lot to think about when I
get home and uh process all this but uh
we're in that we're at the halfway point
now and we we got a lot more to do but
um
it's just been fun living in a van with
four other people and it's like we
haven't killed each other yet you know
it's and your wife is American uh she's
from the Philippines originally yeah and
she uh she moved here when she was about
13.
um and she's a great photographer she's
a fine art photographer day job is a
copyright but um I I just love her so
much uh since we've met my life has just
become better
um just having that like grounding force
uh for that that's what you want yeah
someone who makes your life better yeah
I was scared of that you know like uh
with the the constant need for like
novelty and um
you like to anyone who's watching this
like if you have some of those like
addictive uh relationship traits like I
was very scared to meet someone who
would be like stable I was like life
will be quote unquote like too normal or
whatever but that's just I I think for
the most part that's probably the
[__] like um
uh there's like there's there's a lot of
fear around
like committing to someone or I mean
committing to a life I guess like to
that that doesn't have all those like
constant like searching for like shiny
options on the outside
um but once you get over that hump of of
that fear I think It ultimately is great
it gives you like more space in your
life I guess you know to just have a
home base and have someone you can
depend on both you can depend on each
other and then um you can go out into
the world and do your thing and come
back and uh
uh yeah yeah I appreciate it a lot
that's great yeah it's nice to see
someone whose lives whose life has kind
of
you've healed a lot of your problems and
and you're past it and you're happier
and you're healthier and yeah it's nice
to see that yeah um I I really want like
uh
it's yeah it's kind of hard to talk
about because I don't want to like just
like dwell up I don't want to like get
talk about all my [__] and then be like
look I'm fine now because it's it's not
as simple as that but I but I know for a
fact like progress with mental health is
100 possible like I just I know that
that is doable and if you're struggling
with
um with something like try and try and
make it better uh for yourself don't do
it because someone else told you to do
it or don't do it to live up to like
some other person's idea of what like
your good mental health should be or how
your life should look just take small
steps to slowly start improving your
like what you have
um because it is it is possible to to
improve I think we kind of touched on it
earlier sometimes your brain chemistry
changes as you age yeah yeah and who you
were when you're a teenager in your in
your 20s
is different than who you are in your
30s or 40s or Beyond yeah 100 mellow and
you seem to like yourself more or you
accept yourself more which makes you a
better partner and everything becomes
easier and better as you age yeah I I
agree with that and sometimes I I think
about that too I'm like how much of it
is actually like
I mean it's probably a bit of both how
much of his like hard work and therapy
and all that stuff and how much of it is
just that your brain eventually goes
we're in older mode now things are fine
you know like that like that it slowly
just changes like I feel bad for people
who peek out in their high school years
or 20s that's like because I'm happier
now than I ever was yeah yeah yeah and
I kicked myself like I was I was maybe
physically in my Prime in my 20s or 30s
but I just mentally was not right yeah
yeah we don't get we were not lucky
enough to have that overlap I guess yeah
but but I agree like I mean I'm so happy
now I feel like you know like I seems to
be the same for you but like I'm I'm the
most prolific most organized most
artistic I've ever been in my life and
I'm like I could not have seen that when
I was in the doldrums like I couldn't I
I that wasn't even something I hope for
I was just like that's not a possibility
um and the other thing is too I would
just say like um uh with um with
medication and stuff like that like I
was on
I was on Paxil for like uh maybe eight
years or something like that and um you
know getting on medication is good when
you can be good for you when you have
like all of these issues and it's
important to like either choose
medication or drugs you know not to mix
them or alcohol or the medication
whatever is your crutch or whatever or
is your medicine I would say but um over
time that became um less beneficial to
me than beneficial and it took me about
four years to switch from one medication
to the other and that has been a big
Improvement thing for me too and you're
currently on something I'm on Lexapro
now and a lower dose and then uh
Seroquel as well which is normally an
antipsychotic but it they use it as a
it's like a clean drug they call it as a
sedative for sleeping so those are
common I think yeah yeah yeah and so I'm
taking less of what I less milligrams
but like also a less side effects prone
uh drug and um it's just can't be stated
enough that it's like really important
that like if you if you feel like your
doctors are off or just don't give [__]
like maybe try and look try out another
one
um but the medication for me is like
made a huge difference
um have you tried to wean off of it uh
yeah that's how I ended up in the psych
wards uh the first time yeah that shows
you how important these things are yeah
how helpful they can be yeah yeah and
I'm not I'm you know to each their own
like if you were doing fine with just
smoking weed or whatever that's fine I
don't I don't do any drugs or anything
but the medication has been very helpful
for me but I took I took like two months
to wean myself off it very slowly and I
was like that wasn't so bad and uh after
about a week uh I couldn't sleep I slept
I didn't sleep for like a week it was it
was insane I I fight if I slept it must
have been for a [__] half hour it
would ask it tremendously dark uh yeah
everything got incredibly dark and it
was just it was like just being on a bad
trip all day and uh yeah I ended up in
the hospital and uh a couple of times
and um that was it was I mean it was a
massive learning experience you know it
was [__] terrifying at the time I was
pretty convinced I was going to die but
um and then I had to go back on that
medication which was a super bummer like
you were you I feel like for a lot of us
who go on like these uh antidepressant
stuff you're looking forward to the day
where you can finally get off it and be
normal again and I was like I was like
I'm working out and like this is going
to compensate for the medication not
being in my system but um I just
nosedived after that and I had to go
back on it again a lot of it wasn't so
much just me coming off the medication
but coming off it at the wrong time I
had a lot of stressors in my life so you
don't want to be rushing yourself off
that you want to get to a point where
things are more stable and then come off
it so I've been able to wean off it and
onto the other medication almost without
a hitch about two years after that
initial stint so
um again that's due but I thought I was
stuck in it for my life but a lot of it
just has to do it I think with being
cognizant of what's actually going on in
your life like you hope to just be
perfect and clean again and like a
normal human in society without
medication but I've got a Volcan point
where I just don't care if I'm running
for the rest of my life anymore it's
fine you know it's like there could be
worse things it's not a big deal
um but we'll see I probably eventually
will try and um
see again if I can live life without
that stuff but who knows I don't really
care if it happens or not excellent yeah
machine that's an interesting little
conversation we just had thank you for
having me you're an interesting man
appreciate it thank you so much thanks
Mark
foreign